Hullow everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica [Below Zero :D]
Now, in the last episode, I was a little bit panickD, uh,
considering that this is a new environment and I'm
a Big Bubble-Blowin' Bitch Baby
but that doesn't matter
because I have to go out there.
And I have
my Seaglide now, which means that
I can 'sea' :P, which is good.
And I've got a mapping system, I forgot that was in there,
I never actually- *gasp* OOH
The thunder scares me.
I gotta get some food too, so I'm gonna take these guys.
Um.. whoa
Wait when did I get an- oh no that's
the same drop that was there before, okay (mark is retarted guys)
Is it bad out there? NO THERES FLOWERS AND SHIT.
Ohh
Oh my God
That's so cool!
I imagine that in the future they are going to have even more weather systems available
Probably with like snow storms even though this is kinda a snow storm
Thunder, snow, whatever it is
Anyway
What we gotta do now is we gotta explore a bit farther
We gotta start getting enough resources to build, um
The builder tool
Wait was that even an option I don't remember
Whoa
Hey hey you deployed! Hey good for you man
Proud of you
Alright, um, also I should probably build another battery
Do I even have enough for that?
Probably not
Okay I can't build the builder tool
I don't have the option to build a builder tool yet
So we're gonna forget about that for now
I'm gonna put some shit away
'Cause I'm gonna be out collecting shit anyway
So
Umm
Pretty much only need one of each and then
I'm going to cook these guys into food
AAAAAAAAAAA BUHBUHbuhBUHBUH
Okay what do you got, yum yum
Alright good for me
Okay!
So
I don't exactly know where I'm going
Because I need to get research projects
To be able to do what I need to do
However
I imagine that the game is gonna want me to
Just kinda go out and figure it out for myself
Now what that means, I'm not 100% sure
But I'm just gonna start going and I'm-
(suddenly remembers that its nighttime)
And I'm just gonna see for myself if
I end up in a horrible death situation
Which is very likely. Least I've got the high oxygen tank
Ooo what's down here? Oh!
Oh it's just another hole
Okay
Ehh.. okay
Hello
Oh you're deep down here ;). Ohh what is that?
Is that needed?
What is that, table coral?
Do I need that?
Probably need that right?
For something anyway
Yeahhh yeah yeah I need that
For, uh, computer chips and what not
Right? I can't see shit
Hello?
Oh that's comforting
Alright
Cool
Whoaaa
Weird..
Oh, deep, okay
This probably a way to make the, the locations go away, probably
There we go, I don't need this anymore
And I need to see that, okay
Good to know, thank you
With this and my power I should be able to get out of here. I do want to make another battery before I-
Hey!
How far could I possibly go
That I would need another battery to get out of here?
Whoa
Whoa..
Whoa!
I don't think I should be able to see that through the clouds
But, oh, whoo, hey
Alright then
200 meters down
Where is that exactly?
Wait what do we- what are we talking about
Wait a minute
Alien sanctuary in the twisty bridges
What are the twisty bridges?
I don't get anything on the beacons
I got a whole lot of nothing. A got a little bit of dick and a whole lot of diddly
Oh.. are these the twisty bridges?
Whoaa..
Ohh..
*strange noise*
Ahh!
What is going boom?
What in the world is blowing up?
This has gotta be the twisty bridges right?
Oh AHH AHH oh hey!
You're fine. Are you fine?
You look like you might be lethal
Ohh you're lethal alright
Ohh
Are you the new thresher? Or whatever it was? The toothy thing?
Uh..
Okay I think I am in the twisty bridges
But I don't like being in the twisty bridges
The twisty bridges make me feel like
Maybe I'm not in the right place
Imma wait till sun up
And then I'm- oh it is sun up and that's just how bright it's gonna be, okay.
Alright. Well
Alright then, we're gonna go for it.
This must be the twisty bridges
And she said 200 meters down
I'm just gonna- ahh! I'm gonna go by these things!
Ahh!
You're right I am!
Okay that's great. Hey, what is this? What is this?
What is this? That's a thing
Wow
Uh, what did I get?
What'd I get?
What did I get??
What did- did I just get something?
I didn't- I didn't get anything for that?
What do you mean I didn't get anything for that?
What do you mean? This is a thing!
That was a thing that I just-
Did I break something? Is that not what I was supposed-
Oh my- AHH AHH OH WHAT IS THAT
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS
Wait there was an oxygen down there
Um
Oh what is that? I don't care. I'm getting the oxygen
Oo oo OO OO OO HEY HEY
Okay it doesn't care what I am, okay
That's fine. I can't, lag
Uhhh
Okay
Alright. Is this it? Oh my God!
Oh my God!
Uh, what is that? That's important
Okay. 3/50?
50??
Oh my God.
Oh my- oh!
Ahh!
No!
Just a whole lot of nope on that one
I don't know why I'm here
I don't know- whaat the hell.. oh my God it's beautiful!
Oh my God
Okay, um
I don't have a beacon, I ain't got nothing.
I've- uhh- I've got a whole lot of nothing
Uhh I'm not seeing nothing
So, I don't know if I was supposed to get a beacon
I don't know
But I don't have one
So..
Yeah, I don't know- I don't know what to do about that
Ahhh! Why?
Oh I am going the wrong way!
Holy shit! *scary noise* AHH WHAT IS THAT?
*sigh*
Uhh..
Okay
I think we're fine
I think we're probably fine
Okay
I'm just gonna get back. I'm gonna-
I'm gonna see if there was anything that actually did appear in the, um
In the, uh,
Section, uh, to build shit
Because what I need is the builder tool
But I don't know if I'm gonna get that
But I did access something
It just didn't do anything
You know what I mean?
It was supposed to be something, but nothing happened
I don't know. What do we got? Anything?
Ohhh..
A rebreather
Now that's probably important
Oh yeah, no that's good, because then when I go deeper
It's not gonna be bad
So that's good
I'm- I got a rebreather now
That's good
That's very good
Also
Um
Go ahead and cook this I guess
Alright, rebreather, absorbs and recycles CO2 into breathable air
Conserves oxygen when diving deeper
That- all that is is just it, it um
Oh shit that's full
I didn't think I would get full this soon
But oh well
I guess I am
I can turn these, these two big ass things into uh, lube or something
Or one silicone, one lube
Better than the form that it's in right now
Okay
Alright
Um, deployable...
No
Tools..
Repair tool. I don't have sulfur so I don't even know how to do that
Uh, battery, yes. I wanna make a battery.
I wanna make two batteries actually
Just in case
Sorry!
Just in case, you never know what you're gonna need when you're gonna need it
Okay
Let's put those there
Let's put these away
And.. we're good to go
Okay
Let's get-y outie- Whoa!
Hey buddy, hey buddy, hey buddy, hey
How you doin?
Alright whatever
Alright
Um
It must be something down in those quote unquote twisty bridges
They said something about an alien something or other
I don't know why, I don't know what
But I'm gonna stick my head in the hole down there
Just to prove that
I ain't no bitch
I don't know why I have to prove that
But I'm gonna prove that
You know what? You are not that scary
You're not scary!
Alright, no, you can't catch me though cause I got this
Alright lets go down
I don't like the ominous music swell that happens when I go down here, but
I guess it's alright
Alright, what do we got?
Let's get some oxygen
Uh, there was a crevasse
Right here, yeah
Here, okay
Alright
Crevasse!
Ah! Ah! God! Ahhh!
Ahhhh!
AHHH!
It just goes down!
AHHHH! IT JUST GOES DOWN!
Ee oh oo ee ay
Oo ah ah
Ting tang, walla walla bing bang!
OH EE OO AH AH
HEY EE AH oh
Oh ee oo ah ah
Ee ah ay oh oh!
Wha- is that the bottom?
*scary noise*
AHH! IT'S THE- THE LEVIATHAN!
I don't know what that is!
Oh I don't know, I don't care! I don't care!
I don't know!
Ahhhh!
Okay, I'm just going to assume-
*crashfish noise*
AHH! FUCKING RIGHTEOUS
NOOOOO
*crashfish explodes*
What? What are you talking about?
I haven't seen anything
Ohh, okay
Ah
Ah, yes, I see
I see, I see
Oh, okay
Alright
I see
Okay
Yeah, I don't know what you're leading me into
But, I'm not happy about it
I can tell you that
Tell you that. Data downloads?
I don't have time to read that. Okay. It's not there anyway
Cause it's early access
Alright
Yes please
Good thing they've got all these oxygen plants here.
Those are awfully handy
Those are real handy
Alright these seem to be leading somewhere
There's a couple of them around here now
I don't know what the point of them is, but they're here
*weird noise*
What was that?
Not seeing anything
If I'm hearing it, it might be outside of these cave walls, I'm not 100% sure
But if it isn't, then, *laughs* I'm about to- I'm about to meet him!
Which will be-
*same weird noise*
It's probably nothing
Found the entrance I think?
Uhh..
Hi
What is that?
What, what is that?
Oh!
I swear to God this game is scarier than almost any horror game I've ever played in my life
Alright
Here we are
This looks nice
Just a nice
Normal cave
Where nice, normal people
What am I looking at?
I concede!
Casual
Huh
Alright, well, real casual
I mean, buy me dinner first
As you-
Oh, OW my legs
I shoulda been sprinting
I forgot that I could sprint
Ah, yeah, okay, alright, let's try that again
Take two
Yeah, so, real casual
Um, what is that beacon by the way?
Another supply drop?
Okay, sure, yeah whatever
I didn't know that I was going to get another one
Ehh..
Um, so yeah, like I was saying
I'm not opposed to staying here forever
In fact, that was kinda in the last game what I reserved myself to
I didn't expect to ever go home, so
The idea of even staying in one place forever, but alive, is kinda appealing, ya know?
Ya gotta admit, you know what I'm talking about
Whatever, you computer man
Don't know the difference between an alive computer and a dead person
Alright, cool
Oooo!
That's a thing!
Wow, I've seen things like that-
What?
Die peacefully?
Hey, I can't turn back you- you closed me in here!
That's a bit extreme, okay?
First you want me to stay here forever
And now you want me to die?
But I guess you don't know the difference between life and death
We got a Doctor Manhattan over here
And you're just a big cube
Alright, well
I'm gonna go touch this big green glowy thingy, how about that?
Here we go!
Boink!
Hi, how you doin?
Hey, you doin okay?
Oh, yeah, me!
Oh, I see, I'm the vessel
Ah, ohhhh my brain!
Ahhh!
Ah
Thanks
Thank you for that
PDA not good enough for you I see
No, I don't
You in my head?
Mmm..
Okay
Okay, alright, cool
I won't move
Right
Huh?
I wonder what would happen if I didn't move
Would it have been like a game over sequence, he would have figured it out and then killed me?
That woulda been fun
And, uh, then I would of had to restart but, let's assume he wasn't going to do that
Soo
Let's get out of here apparently
Because that's what we're doing now
I have an alien inside my head
For some reason
He's gonna give me a lot of knowledge on how to live in this frozen world right?
Probably? Yes?
And not kill me
Okay
Sam!
Shit went down
I'm- I'm in a bit of a spot of bother
Okay!
*weird noises again*
Ah that weird noise again
Alright, cool, great
Ehh
Oooo
These silver?
Lead?
Oh that's silver
No, silver
God damn it
I didn't even get lead from the lead one
I don't know what I need lead for but it's something that I don't have yet so
I figured that it woulda been nice to have
Maybe. Silver? God damn where's the lead?
Get the lead out!
Lead?
No
Lead! Got lead!
Okay, I don't know what I need lead for
What is that?
Lead? Two lead
*crashfish noise* AHH NOO THAT'S NOT WHAT I WANTED!
Ahhhh kaboom!
*crashfish explodes*
So I think I know what all the kabooms were
I don't know how I could have forgotten about the kaboom-er
The kaboom-er's kinda like
That one thing that you don't forget in this game
Right up there with levi-o-thans
But I forgot about it
So, that's my bad
So, yeah, Sam
I am in trouble
I am in a bit of-
*crashfish again*
AHH! FUCK GOD DAMN IT
*silence*
No kaboom?
*crashfish once again*
*angry crashfish but no kaboom*
Ehh..
Wha- oo wait.. okay..
*scary noise*
I don't need anything! Thank you!
I'm good!
Apprec- I appreciate- whoa you got close
Where did the- there was another drop!
Whaa- what the frick?
Okay, whatever
I don't know what's happening
I don't care what's happening
I don't need to know what's happening
I just wanna get out of here
It's storming like crazy
Whatever
Let's just get back
I need to talk to Sam
Cause something happened
Real bad
Okay there's two supply drops
Where's this other one?
Ohh
Oh no that's
Isn't that the one that I already saw?
Ah, let me go check it first
It's not too far away
I think that's the one that
I think that's the one that, uh
That it wanted me to get anyway
I think I already got that one
*strange noise*
Boy, this place is just
This place is just full of death
Oh no, it's not, its different
What are you?
Oh!
Alright
Cool
Oh!
Heating gel!
I get to schmear myself with gel!
Oh..
That's awesome!
I love schmearing myself
That's like my favorite thing to do!
I love schmears
Alright, whatever
I haven't experienced anything to do with the cold yet
Or maybe I have and I've been dying slowly to something I don't recognize
You bet
Yes!
Oh, yeah
I already have-
Cargo rocket..
Cargo rocket...
Cargo rocket?
Cargo rocket
Mmm. I- those words just- really not making a lot of sense to me
I, uh, mm..
Oh, um
Am I supposed to do this myself, or
Or, uh, am I supposed to do it this with the thing that they send?
Alright
Um, oo!
There we go
Is that coming down?
Alright, let's find out what that is all about
And then I'll replace the battery once this gets dead
Hey, wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait a minute
Okay, hey-yo
Nope
Oh, do I really have to wait till you fall down?
Is that really what I have to do here?
Is that really what I have to do?
I like the flashlight's light better
It's very, very nice
Very comforting
Very surrounded by death
Oh come on hurry up man, hurry up!
Alright, portable- woww
That's not what I thought it was going to be
Bioscanner, huh?
It's got a big glowy penis on it!
How do I do that?
Should it be?
You got it Sam!
Oh! 500-
Alright, fine
I'm gonna dump some stuff in this storage- this storage locker just be-
Just because it's convenient storage, it's actually quite large
I'm just gonna put a bunch of stuff that I don't immediately need for survival
Like a dead battery
Maybe this gold
Titanium, you know, you don't need that
I can always get titanium
Yeah yeah yeah whatever okay
Let's go to the cargo rocket then, I got nothing better to do
I got a bad feeling about where it's gonna be
But, you know- oh! No it's gonna be on an island!
Interesting
Is it?
It looks like its above the water line
So I'm just, I'm just assuming
Maybe
Huh, you know what I'm gonna miss?
You know what I'm gonna miss?
The big, floating, turds
The big ole things that fall in love with my, my uh, my cyclops
Wow!
You guys really don't need to blow up that much!
Whoa, hey it's the thresher- that's a thresher!
[no it's not]
That's one of those things
Hey, I know you
Wow, hey!
Whoa, hey
Whoa.. hey
Alright, wow!
Hey, what the- what are you?
What are you rock puncher?
Wait, I swear I've seen this guy before
Have I seen this guy before?
Whoaa
Ha ha ha what do you do, punch rocks?
Oh you punch-
Ah! Ah my face!
OW!
Alright, note to self
Don't- don't mock the indigenous lifeforms
Am I going up? Wow, okay here I am
Wow.. look at that glacier
That's beautiful
Um
Yeah, cargo rocket huh?
Uh, about that
Oo, is this a heated pool?
Alright
Um, methinks that this is a bit unfinished
Maybe just a wee tad bit
Helloo
How are you? Good to see you
Helloo how are you?
Yes yes yes
Very warm
Yeah I don't think that they properly implemented
Oh up there?
Yeah I don't know if they properly implemented like the cold system just yet
Or maybe it hasn't gotten cold enough quote unquote because it's kinda raining right now
And once it gets cold, then I'll need to, uh, do something about that
But for now, it's awfully comfortable
Oh I love the old system of climbing up a mountain through a series of unknown caves
Ah..
Alright
See, above water, no scary
No scary at all
Safe, so safe
So fun and free and safe
Hey!
Wow!
Oh, hey!
This place looks great!
This looks really great
Um, this is great
Uh, this is great
[is it great Mark?]
Yeah!
This is great
Alright
Hello! Can I get some coffee?
I can!
Yes please!
Single wall shelf?
Oh you know it baby
PDA: New blueprint acquired
*Mark imitating the PDA noises*
Coffee Machine: Coffee complete
PDA: New blueprint acquired
Alright, coffee
Chair
*Mark imitating noise again*
PDA: New blueprint acquired
Locker
Um, this is a pretty good base here
Actually, surprisingly
Oh hey, lockers!
Alright, let me get this single bed cause this is all I'm going to need in this adventure
Cause I'm so lonely!
*Mark imitating noise again* PDA: new blueprint acquired
Oh, what am I scanning? I don't know what I'm scanning but it's probably important
*again Mark imitates noise* PDA: new blueprint acquired
Yun dun dun dun dun dun dun
Alright, what we got up here?
Hello? I can't go up here, alright
Never mind I didn't want to anyway
I didn't even need to go in this place
Can I scan that? No
Alright well I didn't know exactly why I was supposed to be here in the first place
But I don't think this is the rocket, I think that's probably further up
Helloo?
Hello? Oooo!
That's- Oooo!
You fancy!
Oh you fancy!
Alright, okay, alright I see you
Alright
Well well well, fancy schamncy
Ohh.. rocket needs re-
God damn it! Are you kidding me?
I need to get the repair mod- I don't have sulfur!
Where am I gonna get sulfur?
Okay?
I don't have-
Alright, I get it
I don't know where to get sulfur though
What am I supposed to do about that?
Alright, there's no- like this game just came out, there's not gonna be any maps that are like
get sulfur- wait!
Of course! I was in the sulfuric vents of the area!
Oh I can't just jump off this mountain
Of course!
Of course in the sulfuric vents!
It makes so much sense!
I'm gonna die, this is how I die
This is how I die! This is how I die! This is how I die
Oooo this is how I die
Okay
But if I go to the sulfuric vents, that were just here then of course there would be sulfur in those vents!
Probably
That makes sense!
Right?
Probably, that's why it was in between here and there
I don't have enough of the other stuff that I need
Probably. What do I need for a- what do I need for a repair thing?
Repair tool.. just titanium! I even brought the silicone rubber even though I didn't think that I would need it
Because I'm weird like that and apparently it pays off
I'm gonna fall, I'm gonna die
Okay I'm fine
Now if I could just.. get by
Those goddamn threshers
Alright here we go
Yippee!
Alright
So there's sulfur here- I mean this looks it would be a sulfuric vent type deal
That's generic bowl
Whoa
Oh whoa hi!
Hey, how you doing?
Okay, alright
So that's just gener- there [?]
Eh
What would..
I feel like there would be something here
Sulfuric, right?
Why these vents- it would make sense
Like I've never seen
Sulfur before but
Can't be that- can't be that weird, right?
It's gotta be obvious
Maybe not obvious but-
AH AH OH OH OH OH
Whoa!
Are they- ohhh he wants me! Ah I thought they weren't hostile but apparently they're hostile
Okay
No no no no no no no no no no
Um no
No thank you
Alright
So, what is this?
Magnetite?
Alright, that's not what I'm looking for but at least that's different
Boy, things seem to be a little bit broken in here but
That's okay I'll- wow
Wow wow
Oh!
I can go through that!
I did not think I could go through that
Okay, ooo
Don't like that
But maybe down here?
What's that? That's nothing, oh!
Well that doesn't sound good
Whatever that is
It's a bit of a dead end here
Oh this goes down, oh
Ooo it goes down all right
Oh, hi, how are you?
Okay never mind
Alright
So. Not down there
I don't think anything is down there
They- it looks like they just haven't finished, uhh, putting things in that that area
Ahhh!
Of course!
Okay, I looked this up
Just in case
It's um
It's the thing that is, uh, leftover after the boomer.
Right!
So once the boomer goes BOOM, apparently you go get it from the um
Yeah, from the little plant that it comes in
So yeah
I gotta go back and I gotta trigger one of the boomers to come get me
I think they're actually in here so its nearby
Yeah, so. Come get me!
*crashfish noise*
Ah! Okay there it is. Where?
Ahhh! *crashfish explodes*
Ahh ohh
Hey, okay, don't mind me, don't mind me
Ahhh!
Okay
That worked out really well
Do I just need the one?
I really hope I just need the one
I think I just need the one
Do I just need the one?
Is there something after me?
I'm good baby, I'm good
Let's go
Let's go, let's let's go
Let's.. let's go
Hey why do I gotta send up a biosample of myself?
Why don't they- seems like a big waste of resources just to send, just a little itty bitty sample of myself
I don't even know what it is, green and bulbous
Look at it, it's a weird green blob
I'm sending this up in a rocket
This is, this is worthy of a rocket launch to get it off of a planet
Alright, whatever, I don't make the rules here
Resources seem to be a little improperly spent, but it's not my department
So I'll be back once I get to the fabricator
Alright, hello? My hands not really on that but that's okay I got psychic powers with this alien in my head
Helloo
May I have a one, uh, repair tool please
Thank you kindly
Uh, go to hell
Hope you die
Alright
Looks like we're going to be repairing this thing at night
Can I, why did I just go in water? I'm not 100% sure
But, I'm gonna put this on 5, we're gonna go there
We're gonna go
I feel, I still feel slightly concussed after being punched by a, uh horrible rock crab creature of some kind
But I think I'm going to be able to do some really clever engineering here
There we go!
Perfect!
Easy!
Pop her in!
Pop her in baby!
Good thing that, yeah, oh yeah, send her off
Let's get this bad boy launched
Nothing like a night launch
Go baby!
No, I mean, 5.. 4.. 3.. 2.. 1..
5..ohhkay!
Liftoff!
See ya!
Why don't you come get me now?
She said the thing!
Will I?
Wow
I don't know what I'm repairing
Cool
I don't know
Now, what do you mean?
It's TWO TITANIUM to build a rocket?
Just two titanium?
That's it to build a roocket?
That's all it literally- two titanium? That's all I need to build a rocket in this economy?
I can't believe it- this is gonna hurt
Ahh come on
Okay I am stuck
Aiyeet
Aiyeeeeet
Ow
Alright
So that's good but I gotta get home cause, um, it's dark
Oh no I gotta get home in the dark
Okay, so I know that there's no leviathans from point A to point B
So it shouldn't be too much to consider that I just go from A to B
Maybe
I don't think there's anything else to be done
Besides probably wait for them
What are you doing?
Hey you want to talk to me?
Ohh I'm sorry for bothering you
I'm very sorry
I'm gonna fall off a cliff aren't I?
No I'm good, okay
Hiyup
Okay
Ohh wow that's- this is uncomfy, okay
I'm good on
Pretty much everything
At this point
There's only a few threshers I don't think anything can catch me when I'm going with this thing
And for all I know, they haven't even put a leviathan in this game
Yet
You know that they're gonna
Subnautica devs- they love their leviathans
Like you know that's- that's definitely a fixture in this game
But what I really miss- you know what I really miss?
Is having the constant landmark of the ship
I mean, it's good to have like the mountain and that's kinda nice cause it is a landmark
But at the same time, there's a lot more land here
Like it does feel like there is more land
It doesn't feel nearly as isolated
And I don't know, maybe that makes it worse in ways I don't understand yet
But, for now, it seems like, hey, maybe things ain't so bad after all
You know what I mean?
Yeah, you probably know what I mean
Is this the one I left things in? Cool
Ooo, I don't think I need anything from here
So I think I'm okay
Okay, back home
Whaa?
Okay, it is interesting having a narrative going on in this game
Because the first game was so much about isolation and it's kinda what I said about having that big ship there
With no landmarks anywhere
It made you feel really isolated
I mean, there were islands in the first game, but this one, like, you definitely don't feel nearly as isolated
Number 1, you're talking to your sister from the beginning of the game
And number 2 you've got an alien in your head
That's an experience that pretty much nobody gets to have
And I don't know if I should feel special about that, but I kinda feel a little bit special about that
So, in the meantime, it looks like I have to
Explore
And I don't like the idea of exploring
But, supposedly I have to explore
Great
I
Will
Hard pass, okay
Hard pass. That's enough for this episode
I think I need to get my braveness up a little more
Before I go explore because I'm about to go outside of the boundaries
Of places that I know
And, uh, I don't know how that's gonna go for me but
I'm going to find out
So thank you everyone so much watching
Let me know what you thought in the comments below
As soon as I figure out how to build lockers again, I'm gonna get names going on lockers again
So
Uh, thank you everybody so much for being here
Hope you're enjoying it
Expect a new adventure to start next time
Thanks again, and  [whoops] as always, I will see you in the next video. Ah frick. Bye bye!